Previously we initialized an instance of
RPSGame and assigned it to self.game.
What does self.game refer to?
Take a few seconds to guess.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Since we're in the RPSController class,
self refers to the RPSController,
self.game refers to the game
property of the RPS controller.
In Objective C, just like in swift,
we can use dot syntax to access
properties of an instance of a class.
So if we wanted to say
orchestrate a tie,
we could access the move
property of each turn like this.
Notice that we never wrote any getters
or setters for the game property.
Objective C generated
them automatically.
Swift generates getters and
setters automatically, too.
In fact, you might not even
know what I mean by getters and
setters because in most cases you
can get away with not writing them.
If we were using a custom setter,
the code to set self.game would
look something like this.